[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID KOPF: Starting
your company
is kind of like riding
a bike in San Francisco.
You're going up this hill,
and you're looking at the top,
and then you get to it,
and you feel good you've
accomplished whatever goal.
But a second later, then
you catch your breath,
and you look up, and
you realize, oh, there's
another hill to go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRETT KOPF: I like
to tell people
that I started the company
in fifth grade, which
is a total lie.
But the why behind
it is true, because I
was diagnosed with a bunch
of learning disabilities.
I spent years
struggling in schools.
In high school in Chicago,
I had this teacher
named Ms. Whitefield, and
she was just very patient,
and she cared.
She would spend a bunch of
time with me if I needed it.
And her and my mom would
literally talk every week.
Now, at the time,
Remind didn't exist.
MS. WHITEFIELD: Hey!
BRETT KOPF: Ms. Whitefield!
How's it going?
MS. WHITEFIELD: It's
so great to see you!
BRETT KOPF: You too!
I know it's been forever!
[INAUDIBLE]
MS. WHITEFIELD: Yeah.
BRETT KOPF: I thought
to myself that if I
can give the Ms. Whitefields
of the world superpowers
and make them more efficient,
it could have an enormous impact
on the education system.
Remind is an application
that makes it incredibly
easy for teachers to communicate
with students and parents
over any device.
So I would spend
my time speaking
to hundreds of teachers
across the country
while David was locked in a
room learning how to code.
DAVID KOPF: Learning to
code was one of the hardest
things I ever did.
And we were two
kids from Chicago.
We didn't know the first thing
about starting a company,
but we embarked on this
journey that is now Remind.
BRETT KOPF: Our parents and
some of our closest friends
supported us financially.
SPEAKER 1: I was happy
that the two of you
were together doing something
that you were both passionate
about.
DAVID KOPF: We would talk
to all these teachers.
And when I saw that
enthusiasm from them,
I was like, oh, wow, maybe
we're onto something.
BRETT KOPF: We decided to
move to Silicon Valley.
Before long, some incredibly
well-known investors
started to invest
in the company.
It was validating,
because people were seeing
value in what we were building.
TINA LEMIRE: Kids
forget everything,
and so it's just
a way for me to be
able to communicate and
connect with my students
and their families, and
make sure that everybody's
on the same page.
Yesterday, we went through,
and we did the translation.
One of the great
stories is involving
one of my students, Jason.
He struggled, especially with
turning things in on time.
One day, he came to me.
JASON MURRAY: Then I
was like, I bet you
that if I do all my
work and pass the test,
you'll throw us a party.
TINA LEMIRE: When the
other kids heard about it,
they would communicate
using Remind.
JASON MURRAY: I kept
receiving messages
from Ms. Lemire and
my other classmates
to help me and motivate me.
TINA LEMIRE: As
a result, I lost.
They got to have
an ice cream party.
Remind has helped me to
motivate students like Jason.
JASON MURRAY: My grades were
similar to some of Ms. Lemire's
honors students.
And it just shows that
you can do anything
if you put your mind to it.
BRETT KOPF: By
far, the best thing
about starting and
scaling a company for me
was providing value
and helping people.
The cool thing about
technology is that you
can build it once and scale it.
With Google Play, we've
been able to reach millions
of users we would have
never been able to reach
if that platform did not exist.
We currently have over 23
million active teachers,
students, and parents in
over 90% of US K-12 school
districts.
We believe that the best way to
improve the education system is
to help create and build
relationships between teachers,
students, and parents.
And being the company
that facilitates that--
there's no better feeling.
[MUSIC PLAYING]